the jurgen experience it's um it's
almost like you were talking about the
disney star wars movies
that then it's not a work of art it's
it's a formula
like two plus two is four let's put
those together we'll make some money
instead of the original star wars which
was the hero's journey which was like a
joseph campbell book
it's like there was a beauty and a
purity to it
it's a it's an expression like someone
comes up with an idea and they bring it
to fruition
and then you get to watch and you're
like wow it moves you
the new movies don't move you and it was
a crew
of of um of leaders of thought leaders
that like i was a
as a brian de palma that told george to
put the words at the beginning because
it's like you really
i all i've been feeling like is like
when i talk up to this point i just been
making thx
you know and then the toys from star
wars have not come out first which would
be like
you know like the yeezys or something
like that and now so i'm making the
whole
star wars in real life like backwards
like the product came first kind of like
disney like disney
he was mickey mouse became super popular
before he was able to get all of his
imagineers uh imagineers in
i want to point out you know when people
talk about
being you know self-absorbed or the
center of your own universe
um what's the main character in star
wars name
luke skywalker who created star wars
george lucas
but did he write it but listen to that
last name yeah that's yeah
george luke yes yeah he's the main
character
in star wars he can't stance esther
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love